in this video you're going to learn how
to solve for the inverse trig angle on
the restricted domain so we're going to
go through quite a few examples and
we're going to be referencing the unit
circle here so let's dive into this
video so what we want to do here is we
want to find out what is the sin inverse
of - one2 and what this is really asking
us is saying s of what angle equals one2
now when we talk about restricted domain
see the sign could be negative - one2
over here okay or over here or you could
go around the unit circle you know many
times and end up over here over here and
still get a value of negative one2 so
you see how you're getting multiple
answers but in order for it to be a
function we want for that input there
just to be one output meaning we only
want one answer so to solve this
question here s of what angle equals -2
when you're working with sign the domain
is restricted from PK / 2 to positive
pi/ 2 this way you're only going to get
one answer and remember on the unit
circle the sign is the referring to the
y coordinate so we say hm where is y
equal to 12 or I'm sorry negative2
that's going to be at pi over six now
just some pointers here sometimes
students will say well Mario how come
you didn't say this is like 330 degrees
or 11 pi over 6 well you want to be from
negative piun over 2 to positive piun
over 2 so if you end up in the fourth
quadrant you're going to want to make
that a negative Angle now you probably
remember or learned already in your
class like how to graph sign and S looks
something like this right and you can
see how it fails that horizontal line
test it would cross more than once so
mathematicians they decided Well let's
just restrict it over here from negative
pi/ 2 to positive pi over 2 that way
it'll pass the horizontal line test
we'll only get one answer so that's what
this first one is so let's go to the
next one so letter B what's the cosine
inverse of < tk3 over2 or another way of
saying this is cosine of what angle
equals < tk3 over2 well remember the
cosine on the unit circle is referring
to the x value right so we're really
saying where is x negative root3 over2
well it would be here or over here but
on the restricted domain for cosine
we're just looking at from zero to Pi so
just to draw a little graph of cosine
cosine looks like this right
okay it keeps going right but you see
how it fails the horizontal line test so
what mathematicians decided to do is
they said let's restrict the domain from
here to here so from zero to Pi and if
we do that that's going to put us in the
first and second quadrant we're only
going to get one answer so remember sin
inverse were from Nega Pi / 2 to
positive Pi / 2 cosine inverse were from
0 to Pi so again to answer this question
cosine of what angle equals T3 over2
that occurs right here at 5 5 pi/ 6 so
that's our angle that's our answer for
letter C now what's the tangent inverse
of1 tangent is really saying where is
the ratio of the Y / the x equal to1 and
that's going to occur right here because
aun2 over2 / posun over2 that's 1 it
would also occur over here but for
tangent the restricted domain is from
piun / 2 to positive piun / 2 same as s
so let's go ahead and draw little
picture of our tangent graph we know a
tangent looks like this it has those
asmp tootes at negative pi/ 2 and
positive Pi / 2 but it also repeats you
know it keeps keeps going so it would
fail that horizontal line test unless we
restrict it from negative pi/ 2 to
positive pi/ 2 so you want to remember s
and tangent kind of go together negative
pi over 2 to positive pi over 2 cosine
inverse is kind of a little different
it's from 0 to Pi in the first and
second quadrants But to answer our
question where is tangent 1 that's going
to be right here here atunk over
4 now again you don't want to say oh
that's 315° or 7 piun over4 you just
want to make it when you're in the
fourth quadrant a negative angle okay
let's go to the next one what's the sin
inverse of < tk3 over2 so remember s is
referring to the the Y maybe let's make
a little note here if you're studying s
is like the Y cosine is like the X
tangent is like the Y divided by the X
right so s of what angle equals ot3
over2 is saying where is the y
coordinate < tk3 over2 that's right here
and that's going to beunk
over3 okay let's go to the next one R
cosine of negative 1 now you can see
we're switching notation from this
little minus one that represents the
inverse to using this other way of
writing uh cosine inverse we call that
Arc cosine it's the same thing cosine
inverse Arc cosine it's really asking us
cosine of what angle equals -1 again
remember cosine is the a
so that's going to occur ne1 right here
at Pi so Pi radians how about for letter
F now AR tangent of < tk3 so again we
know tangent the Y overx where is the YX
equal to ro < tk3 well that's going to
be right here at pi
over3 and why is that well see when you
take < tk3
over2 /2 If I multiply the numerator and
denominator by two that's like multiply
by one see how the twos cancel and you
get root 3 over 1 so that's going to be
pi over 3 for this one for letter G
we've got the arc sign of NE 1 so that's
saying the sin inverse of nea1 or the
sign of what angle equals
neg1 and that's going to occur right
here so remember sign is the
y-coordinate and that's at negative pi
over 2 again you don't want to go all
the way around here and say 3 pi over 2
or 270 you want to say uh negative pi/ 2
because we're down there going this way
okay so negative pi over two and let's
see if you can do these other ones on
your own you might want to practice
maybe take a screenshot and see if you
can try to do these we're going to go
through them together but I just wanted
to let you know I'm wearing my uh unit
circle t-shirt here today in honor of
this video so if you want to support the
channel this is kind of a nice way of
doing that I'll have a link in the
description or you might even see these
uh t-shirts listed below the video but
I'll have a link to my Teespring store
where you can uh purchase one of these
videos um one of these t-shirts with the
unit circle on it and support the
channel and I really appreciate that so
let's do these last ones here if you
haven't already AR cosine of - one2 is
saying cosine of what angle equals -
one2 remember the cosine is the x
coordinate so we're saying where is the
x coordinate one2 again remember our
cosine is restricted from 0 to Pi on the
first and second quadrants here that's
going to be right here at 2 pi
over3 and the arc tangent of Z now so
this is saying tangent of what angle
equals z remember tangent y/x so where
would tangent be equal to zero that's
going to be right here 0 over 1 is 0o
see y / X it's also true over here but
remember tangent is restricted from
negative pi/ 2 to positive Pi / 2 so
let's uh this is going to be zero
radians or 0 degrees for letter j the
sin inverse of < tk2 over2 s of what
angle equals < tk22 s is the Y
coordinate s is restricted from piun / 2
to posi piun / 2 and so that's going to
occur
at Pi over4 see like a
45° okay couple more R cosine is zero
cosine of what angle equals z well
cosine we know is the x coordinate where
is x equal to Z that's going to be right
here at Pi / 2 radians and again
remember the cosine is restricted from
zero to Pi so in the first and second
quadrants AR tangent of one tangent of
what angle equals one tangent is the YX
that would be at < tk2 over2 ided byun2
over2 anything divided by itself is one
so that's going to be pi over
4 okay and remember tangent restricted
from negative pi/ 2 to positive Pi / 2
and the last one AR sign of < tk3 over2
s remember is the Y cordinate where is
the y coordinate Roo tk3 over2 that's
going to be right here of course it's
right here too but s AR sign is
restricted from negative piun / 2 to
posit pi/ 2 these two quadrants if
you're here make sure you make it a
negative angle and we want to know where
the Y coordinat ro3 over2 that's right
here at pi over 3
radians so great job if you're able to
follow all these examples if you want to
see another video that I did talking
about these inverse trig uh functions
and finding the angles follow me over to
that video I did right there and we'll
get some more practice I'll see you over
in that video